[Musique]
l'aviation militaire soviétique
lorsqu'on est uni ce qui était la
puissance aérienne de l'ex union
soviétique
on doit abandonner beaucoup d'idées
préconçues tout d'abord rappelons que
l'union soviétique ne se limitait pas la
russie même si cette république en
représenter la plus grande partie
un peu comme l'angleterre pour la grande
bretagne par exemple nico yann qui a
donné son nom un bureau d'études est à
la tête d'une autre républiques
soviétiques arménie
ensuite il n'y aurait pas une mais
plusieurs forces aériennes il y avait
les armes aériennes autonomes de
l'aviation du fonds ou aviation tactique
et l'aviation de transport tout faisant
partie de la force aérienne principal
l'avait s
il existait également une aviation
navale et bien sûr la défense aérienne
qui comprenait les régiments
d'interception et plusieurs milliers de
missiles sol air bien plus que sur tout
le reste de la planète sans doute parce
que l'union soviétique était le pays le
plus étendu du mot
[Musique]
dès sa naissance l'union soviétique
s'est retrouvé entouré d'ennemis
en 1918 quand la guerre civile éclate
les alliés occidentaux qui ont combattu
aux côtés des troupes du tsar tente
d'aider les russes blancs battre les
rouge et bottes cheville
[Musique]
les échouèrent mêlée certains l'urss le
sentiment que les alliés de la guerre
russie étaient des ennemis de l'union
soviétique
les mines proclama donc que les pays
capitalistes chercherait toujours à
détruire l'état communiste c'est une
opinion qui étaient ensuite enseigné
dans les écoles celui qui essaie tout
est amplifié nous fait là s'était pas
présenté
dans les années punk une solitude
chercheurs et allure une planification
nationale centralisée
et il va y est grand
qu'ils étaient fiers de l'antonov un
maxime leurs prix le plus grand avion du
monde et porte drapeau d'une escadrille
de propagande souvent escorté par les
chasseurs qui 5 afin que l'on puisse
juger de sa taille
l'arrivée des nazis au pouvoir en
allemagne dans les années 30 menacé le
jeune état soviétique l'armée rouge déjà
affaibli par les purges et les divisions
internes qui avait éliminé nombre de ses
cadres n'étaient pas prêtes à s'opposer
à une invasion
le 22 juin 1941 vu clairement sa 5
millions d'hommes 190 division contre
l'urss
laissant de larges régions de l'état
ravagé est sous contrôle des nazis
[Musique]
ce conflit est connue sous le nom de
grande guerre patriotique
la luftwaffe reçu l'ordre de détruire
les villes pour défendre la patrie des
milliers de jeunes hommes et femmes de
toutes les républiques de l'union
revenir les groupes de défense aérienne
qui établir des barrages de ballons et
disposèrent de canons antiaériens de
chasseurs la bataille pour le contrôle
du ciel des villes rap l'auront
[Musique]
les chasseurs les plus répandues sur les
yaks au fleix donc pas de 37000 sur
construit ce fut l'une des plus grosses
productions de toute l'histoire de
l'aviation et ce en dépit du fait qu en
septembre et octobre 41 et afin d'éviter
les bombardements toute la production
avait été transféré à l'est souvent dans
des lieux n'y avait que des routes
sommaire aucune voie ferrée
menu pas de pénurie de chasseurs ni de
pilotes
et pas moins de 93 mans des groupes de
défense aérienne surfer héros du nom
soviétique un honneur qui n'était jamais
attribué à la légère
cbf 119 109 il faut que vous 190 faisait
partie des sept mille 300 avions nazis
détruits par les groupes de défense
aérienne qui comportait de nombreux
avions américains les airs un cobra ou
anglais africaine
le sort des armes tourna en faveur des
sceaux dit
des liens particuliers furent créés avec
la france dont quelques pilotes
formèrent une unité spéciale
l'escadrille normandie-niemen qui avec
un score de 237 victoire possède le plus
beau palmarès français de la seconde
guerre mondiale
[Musique]
des milliers de familles en union
soviétique au vu des pères des fils et
même des petits fils servir la défense
de la patrie dans ce que l'on appelait
la guerre patriotique
david hicks choc a effectué pas moins de
huit cent vingt missions de combat
principalement à bord de bombardier sb2
peu de détails ont filtré sur les
campagnes de bombardements massifs avec
des sb deux des quatre et des t2 et
d'autres qui ont déversé autant de
banques sur les forces nazies que les
aviations anglaise et américaine
david un deux fils qui servent
aujourd'hui dans l'aviation
aucune aviation monde avait un sens
aussi prononcé de son histoire que
l'avait vs l'armée de l'air de l'union
soviétique
chaque cas dé visiter le musée de money
mots pour contempler les authentiques la
vache kenya ou mig qui avait repoussé
les envahisseurs
après avoir été diplômés des milliers de
ses cadets commencé année après année la
longue route qui permet de devenir
pilote de combat
dès le début des avions radiocommandés
sont utilisés pour insuffler l'état
d'esprit du combat aérien et l'instinct
qui permet de prouver la position
tactique dominante
ceci n'est jamais enseigné l'ouest
ces jeunes se destinent à une école
militaire d'aviation ils seront formés
et encadrés par des commissaires
politiques
les forces aériennes occidentales ainsi
ce témoin sur des aspects patriotique
aux politiques mêlant l'union soviétique
c'était très important
l'utilisation de planeur est également
très répandu ici à l'aéro club de
vinnitsa en ukraine des biplaces blahnik
d'origine tchèque sont utilisés pour les
premiers cours de pilotage
ce garçon représente la troisième
génération de sa famille à vouloir faire
carrière dans l'aviation soviétique
la plupart des pilotes s'entraînent sur
des planeurs dans les airs au club
beaucoup d'entre eux poursuivant
l'entraînement toujours exigeant à la
voltige sur des avions aussi agile que
les suv 26 yak 55 et 5 53 qui pratiquent
sur ces images le vol en formation et
qui sont d'excellents avions de voltige
[Musique]
après un tel entraînement comme bagage
les élèves sont prêts à faire face aux
exigences des écoles de l'aviation
militaire
ici ils apprennent que chaque mission
commence au sol et doit être planifiée
avec précision
les cours politique eux aussi sont
intensifiées
avant de s'asseoir dans un cockpit les
élèves pouvaient améliorer leurs
compétences sur des simulateurs de vol
des commandants d'unités de première
ligne expérimenté des commissions
politiques leur transmettaient leur
connaissance dès qu'un moment le
permettait
après des semaines d'entraînement
arriver enfin le moment intense du
premier vol
les jays d'entraînement standard et et
des ailes 29 delphine comme ici aider l
39 albatros tous deux construits en
tchécoslovaquie
ce sont de solides avions bien plus
avancée que ce qu'ont connu les cadets
auparavant
dans le cockpit avant l'élève pilote
dispose de toutes les commandes de vol
mais pour le premier vol il à peine plus
qu'un passager
il profite d'un vol durant lequel
instructeur expérimenté lui fait la
démonstration d'une mission complète y
compris le vol en formation serrée
[Applaudissements]
dans les mois suivants chaque cas des
devient non seulement capable de piloter
mais surtout de le faire quelles que
soient les circonstances
[Musique]
et puis arrive le jour de remise du
brevet tous les élèves qui est réussie
deviennent des pilotes qualifiés prêt à
rejoindre une unité
[Musique]
ils sont mutés d'abord dans un régiment
d'entraînement au combat ce qui équivaut
aux unités de conversion opérationnel
occidental
là les gènes brevetés font la
connaissance du mig 21
ce chasseur aux ailes delta a servi dans
bien plus de forces aériennes que
n'importe quel autre avion se destine à
l'entraînement ne sont pas camoufler
mais il conserve les mêmes capacités que
ceux des unités de combat
[Musique]
après s'est familiarisé avec la
combinaison de vol partiellement
pressurisés et leurs casques les élèves
poursuivent leur parcours
[Musique]
chaque pilote a déjà pratiqué le vol en
formation mais maintenant la vitesse et
la puissance a quelque peu augmenté
montant jusqu'à mach 2
chaque mission apporte son lot de
connaissances et d'expériences sur le
maniement des jets de combat
[Musique]
la fin de la formation le pire est prêt
à rejoindre sa première unité
opérationnelle au sein de l'immense
force de l'aviation de première ligne
dans laquelle la plupart des avions a
reçu un camouflage base visibilité
ce mic 21 a été érigé en chef elle à la
gloire d'un pilote soviétique qui a
volontairement percuté avec son avion un
appareil ennemi
derrière cette porte voici le base
aviation combats dans la région de la
sibérie
un des officiers est un atelier hitchock
le plus jeune fils du célèbre vétéran
david anatolie hitchock
son régiment est équipé de mig 21 bis
des millions ont été construits pour les
forces soviétiques
[Musique]
anatolie en scène à ses pilotes comment
naviguer et comment gagner un combat
aérien
les vols sont effectués par perd
généralement on en portant des bottes de
requêtes cuvée c'est 57
les pilotes sont entraînés à attaquer
des cibles au sol avec les roquettes et
leurs canons interne de 23 mm
en combat aérien le mig-21 dispose du
missile qu'à 13 qui ce guide en suivant
les émission infrarouge des réacteurs de
ses cibles
ici le commandant donne une leçon sur
les tactiques d'interception et sur la
nécessité d'être maître de son avion
utilisant une maquette du mig 23
géométrie variable il explique la
prochaine tactique que ses élèves
devront répéter
ils vont monter à 5000 m en volant à 600
kilomètres heure et sur ordre effectue
un demi tonneau suivi d'une demi boucle
pour retrouver leur altitude de départ
à chaque fois que c'est possible les
élèves préparent toute la mission en
marchant sur la piste et en tenant
chacun la position qui leur a assuré
pendant le vol
[Musique]
puis les grandes portes du hangar sourds
et les élèves et leur instructeur
commence le roulage de leurs mig-23 eu
d'entraînement
capable de dépasser mach 2 le mig 23 u
est l'un des avions d'entraînement
courant de l'aviation soviétique
[Musique]
il décolle pas repères d'une piste
proportionnel à la taille du pays
ils vont s'entraîner à l'interception
d'agir ce style à moyenne altitude
rien de très exigeant
mais pour les pilotes inexpérimentés la
gestion du pilotage et à complexité de
l'avion constitue un vrai défi
à l'ouest de l'union soviétique à plus
de dix mille kilomètres de là et à huit
fuseaux horaires de son jeune frère
l'autre au 1er régiment de première
ligne commandé par victor sy tchouk
armés de lance-roquettes cuvée 16 57 et
uv 32,57 leur avion et une autre version
du mig 23 le 23 nf
le canon gsh 23 l bi tube est
opérationnel et armés avant chaque vol
les missiles air air sont des
[Musique]
la tour de mary autorisation décollage
par vagues successives et avec usage de
la poste compte dessus
ces avions sont plus nombreux au sein
d'unités de première ligne que tout
autre avion de combat au monde
[Musique]
le commandant et son l'ailier se dirigea
la zone de combat à bord des avions 46
et 55
chacun est capable de voler à mach 1 2
au niveau de la mer une vitesse qui
n'était alors dépassé par à aucun autre
appareil dans le monde
[Musique]
quelques-uns au sein de l'otan'' pensait
que le mig ne pouvait pas manoeuvrer qui
n'était qu'une espèce de mastodontes
c'était oublier que l'union soviétique a
toujours produit en masse des matériels
adaptés à leur mission
même à basse altitude
ces pilotes portent des masques à
oxygène
arrivé sur la cible ichu caisson
l'ailier bascule temps piqué visant avec
soin et tirant leurs salves de roquettes
supersonique
l'aviation soviétique tirait chaque
année sans doute plus de requêtes que
toutes les forces aériennes du monde
combiné
certains ces appareils transport des
bons classiques ou à sous munitions
guidées par les radars les mig retournés
à leur base
[Applaudissements]
une demi heure plus tard les trains
d'atterrissage sont descendus les
appareils se pose en freinant avec leur
parachute
[Musique]
un par un ils sont pointés par la tour
de contrôle
chaque base soviétique était immense les
pistes et pouvaient faire jusqu'à trois
kilomètres de long
l'un défense aérienne était la mission
du pv au une organisation spécialisée
autonome
leur radar surveiller le ciel 24 heures
sur 24 et 365 jours par an
[Musique]
tout autour des frontières de l'union
soviétique des dizaines de milliers de
radars de 18 types différents monter la
garde contre les avions et missiles et
nuit parmi eux les plus gros et les plus
puissant radar au monde les petits radar
de surveillance et de captation de
cibles étaient employées en grand nombre
par la pv aux nr les troupes elles étant
équipés de roquettes zénith et de
missiles sol air toutes les forces de la
paix vo dans chaque zone était contrôlée
par des centres de commandement protégé
au système et forces défensives étaient
coordonnées
chaque jour des centaines d'engagement
et de poursuite radar été déclenchée sur
à l'air
les troupes répondait instantanément
tous agissant comme si ce n'était pas un
exercice est bien apte à faire
les équipes de lancement se précipiter
dans leur bunker pour préparer contrôler
le dispositif de tir du plus courants
des missiles sol-air levé 750 dont
environ 100000 avait été fabriqué bien
des années auparavant
la plupart de ces armes est énorme mais
âgées étaient en alerte sur les sites
fixes
pierre g
je serais plus première nous les jeunes
c'est le dernier coup
[Musique]
qui de manière
bien ouais
plusieurs milliers de cv 750 étaient
installés sur des camions comme recharge
souvent et voyager sur de longues routes
à travers tout le territoire et
l'exercice permettait d' optimiser de
savoir faire de chaque homme est de
gagner de précieuses secondes dans
l'action
[Musique]
chaque semaine des milliers de nouveaux
soldats la plupart d'entre eux
effectueront leurs périodes de service
militaire obligatoire
s'entraîner aux procédures complexes et
décide de missiles du pv aux adhèrent
les nouveaux étaient encadrés épauler
afin que la performance de chaque unité
est toujours excellente
de temps en temps de jour ou de nuit des
missiles étaient réellement lancée
même si ces armes ne manquez pas chaque
qui a été fait sérieusement contre
destine de téléguider
à chaque lancement le soldat entendez
l'histoire de l'américain francis gurry
poreuse qui le 1er mai 1960 voler au
dessus des républiques soviétiques du
sud avant d'être engagé est descendu par
une batterie de 1750 près de lacie d2
sverdlov
cela ait lieu au cours d'un exercice
bien réel et la réussite fut totale
on rappelait constamment aux troupes
qu'ils étaient chargés de la défense de
la patrie
pour cela et les livres 10 avec dignité
et honneur ils pouvaient faire appel à
plus de dix mille radars de défense
aérienne et bien plus encore de missiles
sam que leurs éventuels adversaires
à l'exception des antimissiles spatiaux
chaque missile sam et son système de
visée est totalement mobile installées
sur les véhicules les plus rapides
pouvant même traverser une rivière
à la différence des nations de l'otan
l'union soviétique disposer d'une force
de transport aérien spécialisé la vt à
l'un de ses avions les plus
représentatives et quilichini elles 76
propulsé par quatre réacteurs des 30
capes et a équipé d'un système de rivers
des vues chine 76 pouvait utiliser des
pistes sommaires très courte avec une
charge utile de 48 heures
quiconque a volé sur les 76 a compris qu
il peut transporter n'importe quoi
n'importe où et à n'importe quel moment
et les équipes de la bta s'entraîne pour
cela sur ces images un pilote récemment
qualifié effectué sa première mission
dans le cockpit d'un 76 appartenant
unités du vestiaire maintes fois
récompensé pour son efficacité
son premier vol est certain c'est qu'on
est sous contrôle de la tour
le 76 retourne sur la piste et utilise
brièvement ses rivers
il y à un grand nombre de ces avions
dans la bâche prêt pour un legs office
combiner
les charges embarquée acculé qu'amanda
soa issue 85 et des blindés bmd
dans la queue de chaque appareil se
trouve un canon multitude de 23 mm
guidés par radar pour repousser les
chasseurs adverse
certains transportent jusqu'à 125
parachutistes ré entraîner
les autres ont des véhicules blindés de
l'artillerie et d'autres chargements
lourd et tous ont pour mission
d'atteindre et de tenir les objectifs au
sol
s'ils peuvent se poser ils pourront
évacuer les blessés quelle que soit la
météo ce que les 1000 prépare
à 750 km heure le nouveau effectué sa
première mission de combat comme
copilote
[Musique]
à l'arrière on voit les marchés qui
s'est installée pour un long vol
[Musique]
sous le cockpit un autre membre
d'équipage le dispatcheur pointe les
zones d'atterrissage à l'aide du radar
et des vitres d'observation c'est lui
qui allume la lumière vers le signal
pour le largage
premier larguer les charges lourdes dont
les véhicules blindés
avant que chaque charge n'atteigne le
sol sa descente est ralentie par des
rétro fusée qui amortissent le contact
[Applaudissements]
puis c'est le tour des trous avec leur
équipement en quelques secondes ils
remplissent le ciel et quelques secondes
plus tard ils ont pris possession du
territoire à nu
dans exercice en quelques minutes une
force blindés mobile avec une puissance
de feu considérable s'est rassemblée au
sol et commencent à avancer
et tandis que les forces aéroportées
commencent leur progression les gros si
les chiens sont de retour à la base
s'il s'agissait d'une vraie campagne de
charger une seconde fois ci les parents
arrivent à capturer un aérodrome intacte
alors que les transporteurs lourds
peuvent décharger leur véhicule blindé
directement par la rampe arrière
[Applaudissements]
bien qu'ils étaient en avions
particulièrement efficace le i lucine 76
ressemble à un jouet à côté de l'antonov
124 ruslan
l'antonov 124 était le plus gros avion
au monde et la foule anglaise avait
chaleureusement accueilli lors du salon
de farnborough en 1988
avec quatre réacteurs lota rêve des 18
et disposant d'une rivers l'antonov 124
a une envergure de 73 mètres 30
à l'intérieur des ailes il ya de la
place pour 230 tonnes de carburant 60 à
70 tonnes de plus que le jumbo 747
et pourtant c'est elle semble bien petit
en regard du fuselage gigantesque
le poids maximum au décollage est de 405
tonnes il masse plus lourde que tout ce
qui a pu jamais décollé
les 24 ou répartis cette masse si bien
que cg on peut utiliser des pistes
sommaires ce qui en fait un transporteur
idéal non seulement pour l'aviation
militaire mais aussi pour l'aéro flotte
pensée vole vers la sibérie
en juillet 1985 un an tu 924 a décollé
avec une charge de 171 tonnes et atteint
dix mille sept cent cinquante mètres
battant ainsi largement le record
précédent établi par un galaxy de lui et
sa force
en 1987 un autre ruslans tu as bien
nouveau record en circuit fermé autour
de l'union soviétique
vingt mille 151 km en 25 min
pour charger des matériel volumineux les
portes avant et arrière peuvent être
ouvertes
les systèmes hydrauliques permettent
d'ouvrir le nez de l'appareil en sept
minutes
ceci offre un accès total à l'intérieur
plus large que celui d'un jumbo jet est
au moins deux fois plus haut
leroux stan que nous voyons sur ces
images et civils mais la version du vt à
pau est emportée pratiquement tous les
types de véhicules ou autre matériel de
l'arsenal soviétique y compris les
radars géant ou bien une paire de chars
d'assaut nice il est 16 20 et ss 25
nucléaires à longue portée ainsi que
leur véhicule de transport
ces systèmes de missiles mobiles qui
couvre l essentiel de l'hémisphère nord
pouvait être redéployées parent
entonnant 124 à peu près n'importe où en
union soviétique
en seulement quelques heures
une des plus grandes réussites de
l'industrie soviétique fut le tupolev
tu-95 qui a volé pour la première fois
en 1954
ap les billes par le tan cet avion
impressionnant et est propulsé par
quatre énormes turbopropulseur de 15
mille chevaux chacun
cet avion allie économie carburant et
vitesse d'un jet grâce à ses hélices
contra rotatives à huit balles
ce fut une réussite exceptionnelle et
quiconque entendu le ronflement sourd
d'un de ses avions qui résonne à des
kilomètres autour du circulaire o drom
ne peut que s'en souvenir
encore plus remarquable cet avion a été
produit en différentes versions pendant
35 ans
les versions principales de cet appareil
ont parfois qui est décliné jusqu'à
quatre sous version
originellement conçue comme bombardier
stratégique à haute altitude
les tu-95 et tu as eu 140 d'aujourd'hui
suivent leur chemin respectif au dessus
de l'hémisphère nord
il est peu vraisemblable que d'autres
avions de combat était capable de
prétendre à rayon d'action sans
ravitaillement en vol de 8000 285 km ce
qui signifie une autonomie de plus de 16
mille kilomètres
de tels avions ont permis à l'union
soviétique de conquérir et garder sa
place de deuxième superpuissance
elle a détrôné la grande bretagne au
sein des nations capables de déployer
leur puissance militaire toujours du
monde
[Musique]
2 les versions les plus répandues qui
survole les mers du monde sont les baird
et de reconnaissance maritime qui
dispose d'un radar ventrale géant et le
tu-154 deux baies râches lanceurs de
missiles de croisière comportant une
cellule totalement nouvelle et d
équipement entièrement différent
parfois les baird et sont escortés par
les escales du 21e tactical fighter wing
de l'alaska air commandes venues de la
base aérienne d'elmendorf
[Musique]
la marine soviétique ou vmf a joué un
rôle primordial dans la surveillance sa
taille et son influence ont largement
augmenté lors des vingt dernières années
sur l'existence
[Musique]
comme vecteur de projection le
porte-avions kiev et c3 sistership
disposait du ya 38 à décollage court
verticale
[Musique]
ce chasseur remportait un canoë dépôt de
roquettes des bombes et des missiles air
air et antinavire
il faisait partie de cette puissante
marine construite sous l'autorité du
grand amiral gorshkov est poursuivi par
l'amiral cher navire
les navires de la bnf avec une puissance
de feu et un nombre de classes de
navires inégalée
[Musique]
chaque unité disposer de ces radars de
ses systèmes de guerre électronique de
ses canons le ces roquettes et de ces
missiles
[Musique]
la meilleure filière pour être intégré
dans un escadron de première ligne était
le diplôme de l'académie gagarine dans
laquelle la formation technique et
politique était la plus pointue
les élèves ne pouvaient imaginer rien de
plus excitant que d'être formés sur le
chat sol que rapide du monde l'énorme
mig-25
pour ça ils sont formés sur les mig 25
rue à double commande
au cours de leur première mission
d'initiation il grimpe à une altitude de
25 km là où le ciel est bleu sombre
alors ils peuvent se sentir seuls
car à mach 3 les incidents surviennent
très vite
si le second cockpit a remplacé les
normes radars l'élève dispose toujours
de quatre pylônes de missiles et les pod
en bout d'aile illumine la cible
après avoir fini le cours sur mig-25 les
pilotes suffisamment bon était affecté
un régime en équipe et 2025
d'interception
même avec quatre des plus gros missiles
air air au monde la puissance
impressionnante des du réacteur r31
propulsait le chasseur de 37 tonnes
comme une balle sur une piste
[Applaudissements]
sur une mission d'entraînement
l'interception chaque avion de la
section de 4 ans porte deux missiles à
guidage radar et deux autres à guidage
infrarouge
même avec cette charge le mig 25 pouvait
intercepté un intrus à 1500 km de sa
base et revenir
il apparaît le plus répandu dans la
recherche
via sion du front était le mic 27 le mic
27 est un dérivé du chasseur mig-23 mais
avec un nouveau réacteur et de
nombreuses différences qui le destine
aux missions air sol à basse altitude
le mic vingt sept était un agent bien
équipé et populaire auprès des pilotes
comme ici le commandant de cette unité
tactique victor salnikoff et de ses
hommes il se prépare pour une mission
d'entraînement crépusculaire
le réacteur r29 300 avait de très bonnes
performances à basse altitude et une
fiabilité à toute épreuve et il faisait
de cette version bien équipée un avion
capable trouver ses cibles et de
survivre des 100 ennemis
par la suite le bureau d'études me que
yann est allé beaucoup plus loin que le
mig 27 bien plus de 500 pilotes de
chasse on est qualifié sur un nouvel
appareil le mig 29
une conception totalement nouvelle le
mig-29 a volé en 1977 et est entrée en
service en 1983 et il était d'une
conception aussi avancé que les
prototypes de chasseurs occidentaux de
cette époque
le nez de la version hub et biplace de
conversion opérationnel reçoit radars
plus petit que celui des versions
monoplace de chasse
un canon de 30 mm est monté à la racine
de l'ale gauche et il fonctionne en
conjonction avec un télémètre laser
à l'arrière se trouvent deux antennes de
protection de guerre électronique
la solidité de la construction du
fuselage est évidente
l'insigne du bureau d'études mikko yann
est fièrement posé sur l'entrée d'air
juste derrière l'imposant train
d'atterrissage avant
le train principal est d'une taille
adaptée à l'utilisation de terrains
sommaires
le train avant se rétracte vers
l'arrière alors que le train principal
se rétracte vers l'avant avec les roues
à l'horizontale dans les ailes
une des spécificités du mig 29 et
commission d'interception pour éviter
d'être détectés le pilote utilise
poisson radars au dessus du nez se
trouve à détecteur qui est le plus
sensible détecteur passif infrarouge
jamais installé sur un chasseur
dans les versions d'entraînement
l'instructeur s'installe à l'arrière et
utilisa périscope pendant les
atterrissages derrière les sièges
éjectables se trouvent les enregistreurs
vidéo utilisée pendant chaque mission
quand ses mig 29 sont arrivés au salon
de farnborough en 1988 tout le monde
s'attendait à des démonstrations en vol
passionnante
mais dans le domaine de l'avionique
beaucoup penser que la technologie
soviétique est en retard sur la
technologie occidentale
les experts américains a expliqué à
l'époque l'utilisation du radar doppler
à impulsions détection et tire vers le
bas n'avait été rendue possible qu en
s'emparant des ce crédit radar du f 18
hornet
ce fut alors une surprise de découvrir
que le mig 29 et un radar qui sous bien
des aspects surclassé celui du hornet et
qui couplé aux détecteurs infrarouges
était d'une grande fiabilité
et même bien plus toutes les
informations nécessaires au vol et est
fourni aux pilotes par un viseur de
casque un raffinement technologique que
les pilotes de l'otan de connurent que
dix ans après l'entrée en service du mig
29 foule comme
[Musique]
sur le mic 29 à les extensions des pieds
de dérive accueille les leurres
thermique et électromagnétique lesquels
ne sont jamais installé sur le mig-29
usb
les versions d'entraînement une chasse
dispose d'une paire de réacteurs
tournent en ce qui est retreinte 3d
le parachute de freinage est installée
entre les deux depuis hier
au décollage et à l'atterrissage
les énormes entrées d'air dr 33 du mig
29 sont fermés pour éviter l'ingestion
de poussière de pierre oudot l'air est
aspiré par le dessus
le mig 29 en configuration de combat
d'école en 240 m le pilote que dans
suite monté la verticale la vitesse de
330 mètres par seconde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à farnborough une des surprises avait
été de voir les mig 29 quasiment
s'arrêter en plein vol et basculer sur
la que les pilotes de mig avait
découvert que cette manoeuvre pouvait
leur et les radars ennemis qui utilisent
l'effet doppler pour suivre les
trajectoires de leurs cimes
[Musique]
le mig-29 pouvait recevoir six missiles
air air une conception moderne et
efficace avec les version à guidage
radar ou infrarouge
il disposait du canon de 30 mm le plus
léger au monde et grâce au système
infrarouge et laser ne ratez jamais sa
cible
le responsable des équipes de conception
du mig et 29 disait
lorsque nous avons su que chaque obus
toucherait sa cible nous avons pu
réduire la quantité de munitions
bien sûr comme tous les avions tactique
soviétique le mig 29 à avait des
systèmes de guerre électronique très
accessible
il était évident pour tous les
spectateurs de farnborough que les
pilotes de mig était très fier de cet
avion capable de voler dans des
positions incroyables il ya des vitesses
inférieures à 100 2
les pilotes avaient coutume de dire on
déteste devoir rentrer pour se poser
[Musique]
angy 1986 un détachement spécial de 6000
29 à d'une sous version antérieure
quitté la base de coûts de lucha près de
moscou pour rejoindre une base en
finlande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette visite de bienvenue permis aux
observateurs occidentaux de jeter un
oeil pour la première fois sur un
chasseur soviétique moderne alors qu'en
1986 le migrateur volet déjà depuis neuf
ans
[Musique]
une démonstration en vol très
intéressante s'est effectué par un
appareil en solo
[Musique]
il était suivi par un vol en formation
de quatre autres appareils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cette époque il n'était pas possible
de réaliser à quel point ces
démonstrations étaient effectués sans
faire appel à toutes les capacités
d'agilité de puissance du mig 29
aujourd'hui en fait nous savons que le
1029 peut effectuer une démonstration
vraiment impressionnant avec un rapport
poussé pour incroyable même avec un
réacteur coupé
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après des débuts modestes le bureau
d'études d'hélicoptères soviétique était
devenu un constructeur de premier plan
le bureau 1000 avait produit un
hélicoptère le 1000m 8 en 1956 qui était
plus gros et plus puissant que son
homologue occidental le cycle
grâce à ses capacités impressionnantes
donc une charge utile supérieure car
truc tonnes il a été construit à plus de
10000 exemplaires
les véhicules pouvaient monter à bord
par les portes arrière et 24 soldats
armés y être installés
et mi-8 ont été exportées vers 40 pays
dont la finlande
[Musique]
de grandes quantités 2008 jouèrent un
rôle important l'afghanistan des
centaines y ont été déployées servant
autant les soviétiques que les forces
gouvernementales afghanes
ils rencontrèrent une puissance de feu
de plus en plus important de la part des
moudjahiddine
pour écraser cette résistance le mi-24 a
également été utilisé en afghanistan
sept hélicoptères de combat lourdement
armés peut mener des missions d'attac
antichars de transport de guerre
électronique ou de reconnaissance
spéciale une indication des capacités du
mi-24 et son record du monde de vitesse
en 1978 avec 370 km
lors des exercices militaires les
soviétiques utiliser les mi-24 les
avions d'attac de façon coordonnée avec
des trucs très mobiles généralement
équipés de blindés légers pour briser
les défenses ennemies
les mi-24 aussi servi pour des missions
anti char ils ont souvent joué un rôle
de support lors des franchissements de
rivières ou d'encerclement des objectifs
stratégiques
l'utilisation d'hélicoptères d'attaqué
peut se révéler dévastatrice
[Musique]
lors de la guerre d'afghanistan les
choses ont été un peu différente et des
convois de camions souvent ramené des
hélicoptères des iliouchine 28 abattues
comme le m8 les mi-24 ont beaucoup servi
en avril
une des armes anti aériens des
moudjahidine et l omission stinger
pour contrer ces termes à guidage
infrarouge des avions soviétiques
larguer des flames une contre-mesure
adapté
le stinger n'était pas réputé pour sa
grande fiabilité
on voit ici à unis 24 voler vers un
stinger bien à l'intérieur de son rayon
d'action mais le missile n'a pas
accroché sa cible
pour épauler le gouvernement sandiniste
au nicaragua
l'union soviétique a fourni 30
hélicoptères en 1986 dont 6 in d
ils étaient tous équipés de
l'électronique nécessaire pour voler de
nuit ou par mauvais temps sur utilisé
principalement pour le supporter a qui
dépensent pour deux coups ils pouvaient
eux même emporté des soldats dans la
cabine arrière
comme tout le matériel soviétique le
mi-24 était solide et destinée à pouvoir
survivre dans les environnements les
plus difficiles
beaucoup d'observateurs occidentaux ont
sous-estimé les technologies soviétiques
les jugeant dépassée en réalité chaque
armes soviétiques étaient conçus et
fabriqués selon des processus aussi
exigeants que ceux de l'ouest
[Musique]
oh